biggest mistake a filmmaker can make
distributing their movie to me I think
one of the big mistakes that I see
happening a lot is the people premiere
their movie at a festival it possibly
one of the big festivals Sundance with
South by Southwest or somewhere and they
go there hoping to get a sale and then
it doesn't happen and they end up just
like us with absolutely a year later
thinking okay we're gonna self destruct
this you know and they've really
squandered that year and especially
their first launch which is the moment
at which they had the most attention and
actually is the time to distribute your
movie you know and I see this again and
again and I see you know people having
that moment and they you know they don't
take it and I think the biggest like I
really feel passionately the biggest
mistake is to think that someone's gonna
come along and take a movie and do it
all for you do it and do it all for you
and make it you know and it's gonna be
amazing and I just think like real
reality of the world right now the film
world is there's so much content you
know there's so many movies out there
the distributors are flooded with stuff
you know and unless your movie is like
got something like really really
extraordinary about it it's really not
gonna it's not gonna get picked up for a
great distribution deal and this is
another thing I think in our industry is
there's a lot of lies it's a
misconception about distribution they
feel like the way it's all reported
obviously in the press is to make
everything sound great like this film
got this deal what they don't tell you
is there's often a service deal you know
the artist of the filmmaker is paying
the company to distribute the movie it's
not being picked up you know like I eat
the filmmakers haven't been paid any
money you know and that's another thing
even movie there are picked up for
distribution often I mean like I hear
again and again from filmmakers they get
zero they get zero money upfront
zero okay and the company is taking all
rights of the film in order to
distribute it but then they don't do
anything that you couldn't really have
done yourself I mean they're not they're
not putting money into advertising or
marketing it you know they're giving you
zero money to take away the rights
because I guess they say that they can
get you better placement on iTunes or
something and you know you know really
like I think just one of the things is
like
if you're making one of these small move
you know like a small movie like this
plan your own distribution take control
of it study this learner you can do it
and you can make money at it and the
biggest mistake is to think that
somebody else can do it better if you've
done if you've done your homework to do
your film do your homework to distribute
your film it's the same thing I mean
it's it's just a different skill set but
it's the same thing and in essence and
the other thing about it is is that you
will then monetize your work so that you
can continue to be it a writer director
and get better at what you do that's
because like you know you know giving up
the rights to your film and really you
know like if you imagine if you could
make a film every year or every two
years and you retain the rights to them
and slowly like they're showing them for
Mayo on demand or vhx and people are
paying and you're getting 90% of the
ticket every time that they pay to see
your film you know slowly if you build
up a few films you'd be making a living
out of it if you've given the rights
away to your movie and you've given them
away for virtually nothing I trust me
you're not gonna see much money from
them ever again and the money in
perpetuity for films is on the digital
platform the digital platform in
perpetuity is where the money is made on
films that's how it's made
you